you must have been doing this oh yeah
and you were how young 6 years old 6
years old I started my first impression
was Gilbert Godfrey and you did kill God
because it was Aladdin not only watch
Disney movies yeah so my uh my
girlfriend at the time she told me that
yes I had a girlfriend girlfriend at 6
yes I had a I had a snow bunny yes I did
she was just snow buddy no it's fine
listen this she was a snow but listen I
was the only like one of the only black
kids in the district come on it wasn't
that big of a choice man come on it was
either me or Jamal like who like who
else so yeah she told me she told me
that she was like yo she said you're
good oh my god you sound so good oh my
god yoga that's so doe and I was like
I'm outing she was like yeah do it again
yes I love it
and then fun fact we actually worked at
the same place when I was 18 and I was
like hey Sarah it's me
it's Jerry you know I mean that's my
real name I don't like using it cuz it
sucks um but you know I would say I said
I was you know I was your boyfriend she
was like oh my god I don't remember that
and I was like oh okay well safe to say
she still works at Petsmart and now I'm
white famous so we're good she's a
manager she's a manager he's a manager
he's a manager he's managing the
pakmar's managing a pet store it's a
come up come up a win is a win
you